the scaled class starship in Nobis was
still suspended against a backdrop of
stars and the colorful glow of distant
nebulas Frozen in the inky void of deep
space calm at least from the outside but
inside the main hall of the ship was far
from the silent Stillness of the Stars
pandemonium hit as the sounds of a
claxon reverberated through metal
corridors each whale punctuated by the
flash of blood red warning lights blue
looked up at the blinking strobing color
and instantly knew what it meant
emergency meeting he muttered to himself
behind the visor of his spacesuit blue
turned heel and ran his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the corridor
he ran as fast as he could in his
spacesuit arriving panting to the
cafeteria his breathless wheezes fogged
up his visor but beyond he could still
see the other six fellow members of the
ship's crew or at least he thought all
six of them were there it was only as he
walked closer than that he spotted
someone was missing white red green
orange yellow and now blue were all
present but where was pink you took your
time blue white declared I was over at
the lower engine you painted back it's
further away sorry I'm late ran as fast
as I could what's the situation here
orange asked well I I think we should
wait for pink to get her before we get
into red started to say only to be
interrupted that's why I called the
meeting green announced pink has gone
missing but that's impossible red
immediately responded drawing a glare
from White I saw pink only a few moments
ago we were both over an electrical to
Blue along with some of the others that
seemed a little bit odd if red and pink
had been close to each other then how
had green known to call the emergency
meeting the room erupted into a brief
debate with white implying in a rather
spiteful way that red knew more than he
was letting on interjecting Blue
suggested that they all split up in
search for pink which was quickly shot
down Wyatt reminded the rest of the
crewmates that their ship was in need of
constant maintenance if they didn't
perform the necessary tasks to keep it
running then the anovis would never
reach its destination report back here
when you're finished white barked as
they all split off blue couldn't help
but wonder what had gotten white more
agitated than normal however little did
any of the crew aboard the anovis
realize but they had picked up a
stowaway the creature had been slipping
through the ventilation system curiously
watching the assembled group in the
cafeteria before they broke away and
headed off into the various different
areas of the ship spotting one of the
crewmates a man wearing a bright orange
spacesuit the thing in the vents felt
oddly drawn to him and slithered off
down the vents in the direction orange
had been heading now while you might be
forgiven for at first expecting this
extra passenger to be some kind of Alien
Parasite that uses human bodies as hosts
before bursting out of their chest only
to then proceed to kill everything thing
in sight then you'd be sorely mistaken
Stand Down Sigourney there are no
Xenomorphs aboard this ship no this
slippery little stowaway was none other
than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as scp-999 otherwise referred to
as the Tickle Monster known for being an
adorable amorphous anomaly resembling a
pile of gelatinous orange matter
scp-999 has long been considered one of
the most harmless and affectionate scps
ever cataloged it has a habit of honing
in on the nearest person and leaping
right at them not as a means to attack
them or attach any scary eight-legged
egg-laying head-hugging creature to any
faces instead as CP 999 offers a loving
Embrace and wholesome nuzzling to a
person's face all while emitting
soothing gurgling and cooing noises as
well as pleasant scents that change
depending on what the person it's
hugging finds most appealing or calming
while not in any way harmful and only
ever acting out of the most well-manned
intentions
scp-999 had been the one responsible for
Pink's disappearance the Tickle Monster
had been discovered by Pink while he was
traveling through a corridor past the
med Bay taking the longer route back to
electrical there 999 had playfully
pounced on the crewmate to offer a hug
this had caused pink to experience the
full effect of scp-9999's anomalous
properties slipping into an
overwhelmingly elated state so while not
currently injured he was calmly relaxing
in a hitting corner of the med Bay with
the rest of the crew completely unaware
of what was going on
scp-9999 had spotted orange and had been
able to recognize the same color as its
own jello-like body drawn to the
crewmate the Tickle Monster snuck
towards orange while his back was turned
busy cleaning out the filters in the O2
chamber before he could turn around and
spot the creature scp-999 leapt to
Orange and lured into the med Bay with
pink not long after blue had finished up
his latest task fixing up the wiring and
storage rushing off his hands he began
casually walking back in the direction
of the cafeteria only to see the Crimson
of Red's spacesuit zip past he was
rushing down the corridor almost like he
had just been caught well red handed
something didn't seem right blue thought
to himself red had seemed pretty
indignant earlier when pink had vanished
although he couldn't say with any
certainty if it was because red really
did know what was going on or if they
were just nervous returning to the
cafeteria however the crew quickly
realized that orange was now gone too
I'm calling it now white declared this
was you red you're up to something I
swear I'm not red pleaded it was hard to
see how sincere's expression was through
the tinted space helmet visor well if
anyone else knows anything or saw
anything then come forward white said to
the group the rest of the crew were
awkwardly shuffling on their feet each
one clearly uncertain but nobody wanting
to come forward and be the first to
speak actually I um blue found
themselves saying I saw red dashing
around in the corridor he seemed like he
was in a hurry or maybe he was up to
something maybe look it doesn't prove
anything you don't know that yellow
chimed in who knows he may have been
eyeing you up as his next victim victim
red exclaimed look I don't know what
you're implying here I haven't killed
anyone nobody said pink and orange were
dead white replied unless you know more
than you're letting on I swear I don't
know what's happening I'm just in the
dark as you all are red insisted in that
case prove it green interjected bluntly
prove you didn't kill orange and pink
how red yelled how can I prove that you
could prove they're both still alive
said yellow completely unaware that pink
and orange were actually still alive he
can't prove it white announced solemnly
because I bet they're not even on the
ship anymore the missing crewmates were
in actuality still aboard the ship in
fact they were having the time of their
lives inside the med Bay with scp-999
but that hadn't stopped the rest of the
crew turning on red come on red blue
side I mean you've got to admit you're
acting a little well not suspicious but
definitely evasive oh sure what just
because I'm wearing red you all think
I'm some kind of murderous traitor red
shouted his desperate pleading tears
obscured by his helmet's visor this is
McCarthyism look why don't you just give
us a straight answer blue offered trying
to remain reasonable and not join the
rapidly growing Witch Hunt because I'm
scared red insisted scare that we'll
find out what yelled leaping at red and
pinning him down quick three you grab
his arms and legs a struggle ensued with
red desperately kicking and flailing
about while green and yellow gripped an
arm and leg blue was reluctant he wanted
to urge everyone to calm down and not do
anything irrational but it was already
too late if he opposed the blame might
shift to him under White's Direction the
crew lifted red up and carried him to
the anovis's outer airlock they threw
red past the inside door which slammed
shut behind him as he turned and started
slamming his hand against the surface
begging for them to let him out his
pleas fell on deaf ears as white threw a
nearby switch the outer door of the
airlock opened and the vacuum of space
pulled red out of the ship practically
firing him out of a hull like a cannon
leaving him to drift away alone and with
limited oxygen in his spacesuit right
now that imposter's been dealt with
everyone get back to work white
announced we need to keep this ship in a
fit state to move blue was speechless he
thought they were just going to hold red
prisoner in a secure part of the ship
until he calmed down in instead he'd
aided his crewmates in murdering one of
their own even the very thought of it
made blue feel sick and he would have
been if he wasn't wearing a space helmet
it all happened so fast he'd barely had
enough time to consider all the facts
after all white it seemed adamant from
the very start that red was somehow
responsible for orange and pink
disappearing but he had no concrete
evidence to base that assumption on then
again where were those missing crewmates
there had been no sign of them no bodies
or discarded suits maybe they weren't on
the ship at all anymore what if white
was right and red had killed them or
Worse what if White had been the one
responsible and blue would just helped
him kill an innocent Spaceman to cover
up his cruel misdeeds of course the
surviving crew were so wrapped up in the
horrifying moral and ethical
implications of the situation that none
of them had thought to check the med Bay
meanwhile scp-999 had found two more new
friends green and yellow the parrot
seemed rather glum since they had just
helped kill red and so the orange blob
of Good Vibes had sought them out now
the two of them plus orange and pink who
were still fine were all enjoying the
company of the Tickle Monster in the med
Bay at the same time though blue was
returning from his tasks of uploading
data over an admin to find only white
left waiting for him in the cafeteria
neither one of them said anything they'd
both already made up their minds in each
one's head the other was the real guilty
party the culprit responsible for the
disappearances and apparent deaths of
the other crewmates both blue and white
were convinced that the other was truly
the Imposter Among Us
oh God enraged they charged at each
other rather than act rationally Maybe
by sticking together and searching the
rest of the ship the two Spacemen
engaged each other in a scuffle your
sauce blue roared punching white in the
stomach causing him to stagger backwards
I'm not the one who sauce white wheezed
rushing back towards blue and shoulder
barging him into the cafeteria floor
they continued their scrap trading blows
until blue was able to throw a punch
that cracked the glass visor of White's
helmet there was a hiss as the air
escaped and white was desperately
fumbling with his helmet trying to plug
the crack blue was able to grab him by
his oxygen tank and drag him towards the
airlock blasting his adversary out into
the unforgiving cold emptiness of space
blue staggered through the ship it was
certain that he received a broken rib
during the fight and hobbled along the
corridors towards Med Bay when the
entrance opened he stared in disbelief
at what he saw sat inside were the
entire crew minus the pair who'd been
ejected from the airlock of course pink
orange green and yellow were playing
with a friendly blob of orange slime
that seemed to have the energy and
enthusiasm of a peck dog the crewmates
were laughing hugging the Tickle Monster
and engaging in tickle fights clearly in
a state of heightened Elation in a
sudden instant of realization the horror
caught up with blue he had just murdered
white and red for enough
both of them were innocent in fact
nobody on the ship was actually missing
just before this horrifying Epiphany
caused blue to suffer an emotional
breakdown
scp-999 glided across the floor towards
him smiling as he knelt to Pat the
orange blob on the head blue suddenly
felt better about the two deaths he'd
been responsible for actually he felt
great compelled to start giggling
uncontrollably as he joined his fellow
surviving crewmates in playing with the
stowaway as cp999 although thanks to
that delightful distraction not one of
the remaining astronauts realized that
their ship was still adrift in space
heading right towards a sun now go check
out scp-999 the Tickle Monster and
scp-5167 when the imposterous sus for
more blobs and imposters